good afternoon my name is Claude Steele
and I'm the Provost of Columbia
University and it is my great pleasure
to welcome you this afternoon to another
world leaders forum this one is
sponsored in partnership with the Earth
Institute the advance consortium on
cooperation conflict and complexity and
the Vail Columbia Center I want to thank
each of these partners for their
contributions of this series our guest
today is Zoe's a Ramos Horta president
of two more leche de his address is
titled from conflict to peace and
sustainable development the timor-leste
experience mr. president welcome and
thank you for coming to spend time with
us this afternoon
a word brief worried about the nature of
our world leaders forum program which
we're very proud of as you'll see
Columbia president Lee Bollinger
launched this program in the year 2003
as a university-wide initiative to
support uninhibited dialogue on the most
pressing economic political
environmental and social questions of
our time questions that with each
passing year have larger and larger
global dimensions to them over the past
seven years of forum has offered an
opportunity for more than 15,000
students faculty and staff to directly
engage important figures from 48 nations
representing all corners of the globe
our experience has confirmed the
animating principle of the world leaders
forum that only through informed
dialogue critical scholarship and a free
exchange of ideas will answer's emerge
to the biggest problems facing the world
today the world leaders forum offers a
unique opportunity to our students and
faculty to engage in conversations with
men and women directly involved in the
major challenges of the 21st century an
opportunity that would be difficult if
not impossible to replicate at any in
any other City or at any other
University we are grateful that heads of
state and others world leaders continue
to express a strong interest in coming
here to speak in this forum president
Ramos Horta life story is in many ways
the story of his nation and his people
he participated in the revolt against
Portuguese occupation of Timor Leste and
then in 1975 just days before the
Indonesian invasion and occupation of
the country he fled and spent the next
24 years in exile fighting to restore
peace and achieve independence in his
nation for these efforts in 1996 Mr
roma-roma-ma Horta excuse me was awarded
the Nobel Peace Prize which he shared
with bishop
Carlos Bello
timor-leste is one of the newest nations
in the world having achieved its formal
independence just eight years ago in
2002 this followed a vote for
independence in 1999 which precipitated
a violent deadly and destructive
backlash from militia groups today this
young nation remains fragile facing many
of the same problems confronting nations
around the globe though in timor-leste
these challenges are magnified by the
fact that frequently they are being
addressed for the first time having
accomplished so much president ramos
horta still has much to do with its
reserves of oil natural gas and minerals
timor-leste is poised for exceptional
economic growth Colombia professor
Jeffrey Sachs director of the Earth
Institute visited timor-leste earlier
this year and predicted that over the
coming decade the nation's economy will
grow at a rate faster than that of
China's this potential growth is a
blessing though it means that the
president and the nation other leaders
now are faced with the challenge of
using these resources widely and
developing them in a sustainable manner
mr. president we are extremely
interested in hearing from you today
please welcome to Colombia's world
leaders forum president Romo Horta
mr. Provost Jeffrey
Sark's thank you for giving me the
opportunity to be here today a
university that I know a bit as I was
telling the Provost I spent I did some
courses here in 1983-84 one of my
professors was busy in ski I did u.s.
national the course at the time was
called US national security policies in
the 80s and a few months ago I visit
remote school in a town called veni
Lalli many hours away from Delhi I went
there with the US ambassador that then
US ambassador hands claimed I had
donated books and computers to that
school actually at a time when I donate
made a donation was Prime Minister and I
sign off what was and remains an illegal
permit to a church school there to have
the first separate internet satellite
connection illegal because we have a
agreement with Teemu telecom Portugal
telecom which has monopoly and the Prime
Minister of the country is the first to
violate that agreement by signing off
authorization to that school to have a
internet access and not only that I even
gave them computers and $17,000 so few
months ago I went there with a hands
claim and I told me come and see the
books that I donated to this school and
what were the books ancient history
one of the books
ridiculous title ridiculous because why
would someone in venilale want that book
it's that book was us-soviet relations
well big and irony is that only a few
years ago two decades ago that that
theme was very important today we are
talking about defunct entities this
illustrate also the extraordinary
mind-boggling changes that happen in the
late 80s and 90s that actually enabled
the independence of timor-leste our
independence was achieved through a
convergence of so many factors some may
be not planned by us but worked on by
ours believed by ours
others were totally unplanned like the
collapse of the Soviet Union first
followed by the gradual in the
liberation of so many other countries
that were at a time subject to were
dependent on with victims of the Cold
War like South Africa apartheid and many
dictatorships but then another event
took place expected by many I claimed to
have anticipated it because the claim
can be verified on the files of CNN
anyone without call rich arose in the
problem diplomatic license who
interviewed me
may 15 1960 so before the Nobel Peace
Prize but he was generous enough to
bring a nonentity on CNN for 24 minutes
on that interview I said we
in two to three years the Suharto regime
is going to collapse under the weight of
corruption mismanagement and increasing
legitimacy that was May 15 16 96 May
21st 98 so hard to fell students were by
the tens of thousands in the streets
because of the then of that you know
severe economic financial crisis which
some economies predicted but again like
that crisis that effect that started
Wall Street and affect the rest of the
world were predicted by many so that
brought about changes in Indonesia and
enable a more expeditious resolution of
the timber problem in 99 so maybe for
you to understand you know the
challenges that we face some of you
probably had been to timor-leste many
graduates from this university have been
there
Rebecca shear angle spent many years
there in timor-leste a graduate from
here another one Sierra James still
there she went there for a few weeks and
end up staying always now six years and
still there and she graduate from the
master's in conflict resolution our
ambassador in Washington Constantia
Pinto
a graduate he did his master's here at
Columbia and so some of you many of you
in this university or familiar or David
Phillips here been to timor-leste
also very engaged with timor-leste for
many years so for you from any of you
probably what I will be saying is not
new but for the benefit of the students
those who are not familiar let me say
imagine you know one of you in 99
found yourself to be a leader in
timor-leste you had a country that was
totally destroyed in some areas 100%
destruction like Manitou - not a single
infrastructure standing except for the
roads because they couldn't they didn't
have time to dig up the roads and or
blow up the bridges but every building
school health clinic were destroyed
nearly the capital seventy-five percent
more or less destroyed and like that
only few escaped bow cow escaped only
like 15 percent destroyed and you in 99
you also would have found a profoundly
traumatized people traumatize you mili
ated from decades of violence all sort
of in dignities inflicted on the people
you found all three ninety-nine that the
court of a million people had been
displaced out of population of about 900
thousand you'd have found that there was
not a semblance of administration was
functioning you would found that there
was no health no schools ninety percent
of the schools were destroyed no clinic
so that was you were the leader we were
there in 99 of course there was massive
international response they impact the
result of it of the billions of dollars
that were claimed to have been spent on
a steamer we would have to further
analyze but yes there was some positive
impact I think one of the single most
important achievement of that massive
international assistance was averting a
humanitarian catastrophe following that
complete destruction of the country of
the economy this
of people's lives in the communities
uprooting almost everyone away from
their villages when the first but a
troopers arrive from the Interfaith from
Australia the first aid workers arrived
they were shocked that they didn't see
anyone not live in person in the
districts because people were scattered
all over the country or outside the
country in Indonesia particular in West
Timor in Australia and so on and a
result of that and with influx of people
returning there could have been a major
humanitarian catastrophe
we concede it was very very positive but
you would have been told also a lead of
the country will being told by the UN
that the UN will assist you in two years
to build a functioning democratic state
with all the trappings of the state all
the institutions a constitution a
parliament judiciary public
administration and functioning economy
well because that's what the UN was
mandated to do by the Security Council
Kofi Annan secretary-general then pass
on responsibilities to his special
representative Sergio Vieira de Mello
and working with us trying to have a
timor-leste ready for handover
independence on midnight
may 19 - oh who actually one day
speaking in Security Council few years
later and a lunch with members of the
council I asked them do you people
really believe seriously that you can
have a name
and state democratic institutions build
up over two years I asked them whether
any one of them had experience in
running a small Chinese takeaway
business in Manhattan obviously they all
look at me blank because none of them
actually ever done it is neither myself
but I made up a story and I told them I
said listen from my knowledge in New
York it takes you 2 to 3 years to have a
viable sustainable takeaway business in
Manhattan and they look at me actually
sometime later a friend of mine and a
New Yorker who actually knows more about
to business she said no no it's 5 to 7
years before you can actually well but
and then I said if you cannot have a
functioning takeaway business read in
two three years can you have a
nation-state from ground zero from zero
in to three years well the ambassador of
Ghana at the time member of the Security
Council non permanent member he said
responding to my comments when he walked
into the Security Council meeting he was
of the mind that the UN should not
continue in timbal because it was
already too much but after he heard my
comparison or was a Chinese takeaway
business he said changed his mind he
said we are not serious so the UN
presence in Timor Leste from end of 99
to 2002 primarily served to avert a
humanitarian catastrophe and they built
this led to the sketches of a state but
then it was incumbent upon you if you
were the leaders at the time to do the
rest after the departure of the one and
how would you do it with in 2002 2003
with a budget
less than seventy million dollars that
was our budget and the government's most
of them with few notable exception some
exceptions like Portugal totally
sympathetic and understanding Australia
somewhat also in that - they were
flexible in providing direct budget
support but vast majority then and now
prefer to manage the development
assistance themselves there were far
more development a system let's say even
today back then something like two
hundred million dollars as against our
50 million seventy million dollar budget
but managed entirely by the donor
community either through other
multilateral bodies like the various UN
agencies or subcontract international
NGOs to do it well the result is in 207
206 207 a World Bank survey indicated
that from 201 to 206 207 poverty
actually increased in timor-leste and as
it happened with us with amore Lester as
it happened with African countries and
many others the Western media blame who
they blame us they blame the little East
Amore's they blame the little Africans
Asians for mismanagement for corruption
for incompetence they don't even bother
pointing out that the great the some of
the money was not even never handed over
to day will people concern so someone
else should look themselves in the
mirror and say what have we done wrong
done wrong in timor-leste down wrong in
Afghanistan in Haiti and so many other
places where foreign aid
of the past 50 years has not delivered
has not pulled people out of poverty so
that's our challenge is in timor-leste
but simultaneously with all of these we
had to deal with the wounds of the
people the wounds of the soul of the
heart you don't deal with people in
abstract you deal with people in us
individuals each of them with their
history of suffering of pain and only
when you understand what individuals go
through in timor-leste or any other
places then you can really help the
country pull out of the problems when I
discussed with Kofi Annan September 99
about who to choose to go to timor-leste
especially on Trek intelligence I talked
of a non please you are dealing with a
very traumatized people in appointing a
special presentative do not think only
of his or her professional academic
qualifications above all we need human
beings with hearts with compassion
that's what leadership is all about
particularly in countries like ours
post-conflict countries you need people
who have a heart whatever feeling
because otherwise you deal only with
numbers with arithmetic you don't
understand human beings so because we
had to deal with the 250,000 people
coming from West Timor we had to
reconcile the timrie society itself
we had to normalize relations with our
neighbors like Indonesia Indonesia so
that's what we have done all these years
the UN just held a summit on Millennium
Development Goals we came into the
picture of course two years later you
know when did the Millennium Development
Goals were declared was published was
2000 before Timor independence
and it was only by 2004 that the first
targets word is set by timor-leste so we
are unlike other countries that they
should show more of the past ten years
we should be have the allowance that we
came in late and from absolute and
ground zero we didn't start like Namibia
we didn't start like Fiji or Samoan
Islands we start from Ground Zero and
the past 2000 and yet today particularly
in the last two three years benefiting
from God's blessings to timor-leste and
I say and that is not the result of our
ingenuity because we didn't create the
oil and gas it was a God gave it to us
and we are just absolutely lucky frankly
if we didn't have the revenues from oil
and gas what would we do our non oil and
gas revenues amount something like forty
million dollars our Minister of Finance
is here Emilia Paris sitting right there
and would know better better the fish
frankly I would have nightmares to be
President to be Prime Minister to be
foreigners of my country because I would
have to do like we did in 2000-2001
going to Europe to Washington begging
for budget support for more development
assistance today we are 100%
self-sufficient in our budget
requirements we do not need budget
support we meet the budget with our oil
and gas revenues from the petroleum fund
we also happy pleased to say that
poverty has been reduced in the last two
three years to reduce by nine percent
child mortality has been dramatically
reduced and the five mortality reduce
malaria dengue have been reduced but it
is a long way before we meet the 200 15
target but I'm optimistic in conditions
of peace and stability
continuing peacefully that we live today
with the government the people having
ownership of our policies of our
resources to execute policies that meet
the basic expectation of the people I
believe we can fast track achievements
of Millennium Development Goals at least
some of them most of them by 200 15 or
to all 17 it doesn't mean that I some
other good news is that today before
rushing here I had a brief conversation
with Secretary of State Hillary Clinton
and she asked about whether we have a a
petroleum fund
I said yes we do was created in 204 205
the first revenues came in a bit over
less than 200 million in 205 we started
with that today is a we have about six
billion dollars mostly invested in US
Treasury bonds under our law but I have
a letter from extractive industries
transparency initiative the letter
addressed to me July 2 to all 10 in
which they say the Chairman say very
pleased to say that timor-leste is first
in Asia to have met all the strict
criteria in transparence in the e a EITI
rules and number one in Asia in number
three in the world this is particularly
important because we hope to counter the
so-called resource curse in that
governments that are not committed to
basic standards of governance have
indiscriminate easy access to the oil or
gas money to finance whatever it occurs
to the head of state or to the prime
minister they access to the petroleum
fund go through the lengthy
parliamentary and budget process the
government has to submit the budget the
budget goes to the Parliament at least
one month scrutinized by everybody
including government-owned parties and
then it is approved by the Parliament
and promulgated into law by the
president we the president even have a
chance to veto if he or she in this case
he does not agree with the priorities
that are there in the
I haven't had the need to send back to
the Parliament any budget what has been
some of the main features of our budget
in the last two three years that meet
our moral obligations moral obligations
that also make economic sense and that
is we do direct cash transfers to poor
people
I'm unknown economist I'm more I would
say a generalist and sometimes my own
economic ideas of think it might sound
absurd but I think we in life we have to
have also be guided by a bit of common
sense and I used to tell the previous
prime minister dr. Muriel kathiria's
Murray you can be very proud of how fat
our a petroleum account is getting
because you know money was coming in and
coming in and so on because of the oil
price commodities price increase and
they said but you had to find a way to
transfer some of the money back to the
people because as oil price goes up
there is less money in the pocket of the
people because we have to oil price
decrease means other commodities that
derive from petroleum industries also
increase everything else so you have to
find a way and I made the simple
simplistic argument maybe the simplest
argument is this if we give money to the
poor a poor lady and old lady in a
village an old man barefoot he or she is
not going to immediately book a ticket
going to Bali to Singapore to buy
lipsticks or perfumes he or she who will
buy more vegetable more eggs in the
community so it's a model obligation on
our part to help the poor to share with
them the easiest way
but also make economic sense so that's
what the government is doing 60 anyone
over the age of 60 get today $30 a month
payable every six months veterans widows
orphans get cash transfer but do not
think that we are so naive that we think
the economy can run just like that now
we are also the government is finalizing
a strategic development plan that is
soon will go to the Parliament and we
hope that I hope that it becomes a
national document a blueprint that is
endorsed by everybody because it's for
the long term one year to 20 year plan
what we can achieve in one year we
review it every year and what Tim will
look like in 2030 from our situations
today LDC fragile to the upper middle
income country where there is no more
poverty no illiteracy ladies electricity
internet for everybody with food
security some of the things that we have
pledged are now being realized when we
are starting even before the plane is
being executed we already started with
some initiatives from what I share with
you earlier where we were in 99 where we
are today dramatic transformations the
country is at peace today we have it
today if you look at the UN and police
data so some of the lowest crime rate in
the world lower than New York that's
probably not so difficult
I can read it to you
assault data countries comparison
timor-leste 100 well let's start with
the u.s. us 795 cases per 100,000 people
in 208 in 2008 Australia 796 cases for
every 100,000 people also in 208
timor-leste 208 one 169 point one case
of assault homicide compare with
Washington DC I might be biased I will
issues that were cities in the West I
wouldn't compare with Iowa I were almost
no crime here it says almost blank I
were Washington State also very low
Kentucky very low California Washington
DC 30.8 pair a hundred thousand homicide
Timor Leste three point two this has
been of course it doesn't mean that the
situation is a final that we have a
consolidated institutions that we have a
consolidated peace in the country the
mere fact that we are only eight years
old country an infant country it means
institutions our infant therefore it
means the country is fragile we are
together with many other countries in
the world that are classified as fragile
but I reject the notion particularly
famous or infamous American scholar not
from this University
from John Hopkins in an interview about
a year ago to an obscure Australian
magazine called diplomacy
he said Timur was a failed state and
that is a god what's his name he wrote
the end of history
Fukuyama who never who never been to
Timor and but this camera Timur is a
failed state and no we are a fragile
state partly because we are young we are
new we are fragile because institutions
are fragile we are fragile because we
still have to handle with absolute care
the human beings the soul of the people
the crisis that we had in the past
particularly in 206 in part was a
failure of leadership in addressing some
of the issues that were quite visible to
all and that was when we deal with
fragile situations with post-conflict
societies our speeches our public
rhetoric can be very positive in
inspiring leading people towards peace
or they can inflame passions when we
deal with situations like ours
dialogue and dialogue and dialogue
absolutely necessary to avoid suspicion
to embrace everybody so that no one
feels excluded these are some of our
experience of why the 206 crisis came
about came about also because the
institutions are young and new in the
police in the army but we have made
tremendous progress in reforming our the
police and Defence Force long way to go
before we can say that yes timor-leste
is finally consolidated peace and
democracy in the country but I am
please are happy to say that with
partnership from the international
community not always the best but it
would be unfair or would be ungrateful
if you were to say that we did it all
alone
they secured the UN particular Security
Council has committed to timor-leste far
more in proportion that other more
needed situations in the world and
that's partly because we have
exceptional friends in Washington
I mean administration in the Congress in
Europe support from many members of
civil society in this country who in
spite of some disappointment with us and
10 years after independence we still
have not given up continue to believe in
the dream of a peaceful democratic East
Timor and I thank you all and I think I
should end here to give time for
questions and answer thank you
mr. president thank you for not only a
wonderful address but wonderful news
about Timur and but you'll also be happy
to know that since your student days
here crime in New York has also come
down sharply and I was just reviewing
word the lowest just about the lowest
murder rate of any major city in the
United States but six point three four
hundred thousand in 2008 compared to
Timor three point two so we're on our
way and violent crime fell seventy five
percent between 1982 and 2005 so you're
welcome back to a good New York you were
here as a student and actually one of
the peak peak periods of crime in this
city and good good that it's come down
but we're gonna follow your lead to keep
it keep it coming down further wonderful
opportunity for a great and experienced
world leader so I encourage students to
come up to the microphone to ask
questions when you do please identify
yourself your name and where you are in
in the program hello my name is Ali Shah
again I'm from Kazakhstan I'm here
studying as cough continuing education
at the American language program and I
wanted to ask mr. president what was the
hardest thing to do for you as a leader
on your path till this moment thank you
hi my name is Kara chesil and I'm in
master's student in the economics and
education program and mr. president my
question is what you see as the
president's role your role in promoting
quality education and Tamar and can you
speak to the issue of language
instruction or language of instruction
in Timor and what you see the
government's role and what the
government can and will do to promote
positive education policies surrounding
this issue thank you
my name is David Dogon I'm a student
from South Africa in the master for
master's science for chemical
engineering coming from a relatively new
democratic country another one of the
things that concerns me is that the
country is breeding leaders that can
continue a positive transformation and
I'd like to know how confident you are
that that East Timor will also be able
to develop leaders from whatever
channels necessary so the transformation
continues into the future that David
Phillips I'm the director of the program
on peace building and rights
that's the Institute for the Study of
human rights here at Columbia you asked
a question rhetorically about what we
can learn in settings like Afghanistan
from East Timor his experience in many
ways the parallel of East Timor is
history and what we're confronting in in
Afghanistan today are striking if you
were counseling NATO on its operations
and its withdrawal strategy what kind of
tactics and approach would you recommend
for easy questions first we'll do Middle
East peace at a moment how what was the
most difficult
well one during the struggle for
independence - in the circumstances
where we were fighting you couldn't find
one of the most isolated struggles in
the world that was East Timor Indonesia
was supported by every major powers in
the world for different reasons
even after the Cold War and then to
fight on in in timor-leste itself those
were there all those of ours abroad well
you have to have a very very strong
sense of duty of response
ability to do it you know because the
most people probably would simply find
as I was told when I was living here in
New York because I spent many years here
find a regular job a real job and in
particular when you don't have anything
no money at all you know for me to take
the course here at Columbia was very
expensive at that time I remember to a
$3,000 just for three credit course who
paid my course was the Riverside Church
across the street not far from here
475 Riverside Church the Methodist
officer under an item they had stress
distress student or distress something
and they pay for my course and they also
helped me by ask him offering me to do
translations for them because I speak
few languages so I do translations from
French into English Portuguese Spanish
into English from a project that I
received from different countries and
all translate ten dollars a page and
they they were not even complaining that
you know my pages had very few lines you
know I live in a triple space you know
instead of doing that they started doing
the honest thing you know single space
you do table space well handed him to
continue on you know so but then back in
the country particularly you know
someone like our prime minister xanana
gusmo you know he spent years in the
mountains in the jungles he saw people
dying next to him he saw his comrades
you know his compaeros de armas you
know dying the people fed him shelter
him he wouldn't be alive one minute if
it were not for people shattering hiding
and feeding and it is this disconnection
to the people living the struggle that
drive him and drive us to serve them to
do the best and the people don't ask
much even you know whenever I travel
frequently in the country and of course
people complain about I have a program a
TV program not like Google Chavez in a -
mine is shorter his his his 90-minute
program called the road to peace and
national unity
Dalen badami know who needed knows you
know I suppose I speak for 10-15 minutes
to introduce the theme with a moderator
and people are supposed to you know
comment back about ideas to the
president how to build peace how of
course no one talked about they about
this theme they all talk about mr.
president is a really very good idea
road to peace and naturally but how
about a road to my village
they talk about water they talk about
electricity which is positive because
people are no longer obsessed fear about
security in more than one year this is a
monthly problem more than one year I
have not heard a single question on
peace and security issues then when you
talk with the youth they ask for sports
equipment music equipment they don't ask
for anything out of this planet and what
is most frustrating is that often even
these small things I ask we find it
difficult to deliver to deliver Road to
the villages because we have
difficulties of capacity you know
execution we have the money but we still
have a very weak personnel that can
deliver so that's very frustrating
second issue was one about the for the
next generation well we have already in
the government if you look at our
government today the current government
I would say 80% are people who are very
young when Indonesia invaded the country
they grew up under Indonesia so the
young generation already taken over you
look at our national parliament vast
majority and people and almost 30
percent of the deputies are women in our
national parliament what is the
percentage in the US Congress in the in
Europe the percentage in European Union
is 18 percent women deputies timber is
almost 30 percent we just inaugurated
the first sitting will be in November of
a permanent Youth Parliament election
took place few weeks ago a few months
ago I was the promoter initiator of this
concept this idea and I insisted I I
wanted 50 percent boys 50 percent girls
I was surprised the other day I was told
by those who organized the election that
there were more girls deputies than boys
60 percent goes
ages from 13 I think 13 to 19 the first
sitting will be in November this is what
I thought of and believed to be a very
good leadership development program that
early on we invite the youth to
participate in thinking in reflection in
decision-making about leadership so
responsibility for us we had a meeting
recently all the leaders with the church
in a small town Mobe see the older
generation of leaders to talk about the
future what we are going to hand over
that is our challenge responsibility to
work with a new generation so that they
are able to continue or do better there
has been doing in the last few years of
independence third question was on this
sorry I forgot the third question our
language well levels of instruction in
timor-leste for the time being is tatto
the national language and the portuguese
we have two official languages
Portuguese and teton Tatem is a malay
based language spoken by 84% of the
people and the new new statistics
portuguese about 15% 34% speak bahasa
indonesia and less than 2% English but
both English and bahasa indonesia are
working languages as well in our
constitution we have we have been you
know challenging about why adopting
Portuguese as official language one of
the best friends of Timor Leste a great
American senator who once ran for the
White House I totally supported him at
least would be someone I knew well in
the
House and Senator Tom Harkin from Iowa
he hosted a coffee for me in Washington
DC in the Senate wonderful human being
he went and physically brought everybody
to have coffee with me from Ted Kennedy
to Joe Biden everybody and then he said
you say you know we love you anything
you need in this house we always support
but I have to ask a question why did you
choose Portuguese as official language
if you were to choose English
timor-leste would jump start into 21st
century I answer Tom are you suggesting
that your former colony Liberia is also
is already in the 21st century
well I then elaborate further about
other english-speaking countries around
the world and conversely Japan with
other news English official language
must be in the 18th century Italy France
must be he seems that well English is
important isn't a commodity you know you
don't need to have it official language
everybody
once you use English to access trade
Commerce but languages has more to do
with history with identity some would
say but what Portuguese has to do with
the Timor identity
he's been there for hundreds of years it
is a Portuguese colonization that
created this concept of people of his
team what is this people of his team an
topologically that exists is a political
concept like almost anywhere on the
African continent the modern nation
states of Africa except Ethiopia result
of the arbitrary divisions of Africa at
the Berlin conference some a francophone
some Anglophone one little country
Equatorial Guinea is spanish-speaking
but now they seem to want to abandon
Spanish and the Portuguese becoming
official language in a couture
Guinea and Equatorial Guinea has applied
to join the community of Portuguese
speaking countries so that's the but I
do understand and we ask ourselves often
this dilemma what would you know to
teach the children in elementary school
what language of instruction you use
Portuguese when the kids don't even
speak a word of Portuguese what language
of instruction is a bit like you know
you teach use Chinese language of
instruction to some young kids in
Manhattan who never had any contact with
Chinese so that's again is one of the
challenges there a particularity of
timor-leste that because of the
colonization occupation by Indonesian to
205 in for 24 years
we had also to struggle with the issue
of languages and identity and sorry
third last question as Debbie Philip
well
far apart in complexities and so on
fortunately but as I will be signing my
speech Saturday I hope I will have a
good attendance like Barack Obama here
today I'll be so offended if there will
be only one third of attendance and it
is amazing you know you hear about you
know the criticism of the US all over
the world they're like the polls in Iran
that you know in the lowest possible
steam but then the US president watch
and it's not only Barack Obama you know
also the previous president I was there
when George W Bush speak the room is
full everybody
attentive the moment he finished the
poor guys who speak second after a
complete couch I I will never want to
speak after the US president or before
because everybody so excited waiting for
the US president come in
and if you are they're speaking like
today the Swiss president people were
aggravated come on finish your speech we
want to you know we want to listen to
Barack Obama so but I'll be referring to
some internal issues Saturday I don't
know how many people will listen you
know we have this ritual every year you
know we go we speak at the UN I wonder
how many people actually listen so my
decision
I will not print the speech I'm not
going to waste money and paper 300
copies that you distribute and no one
reads it you like what I see it you know
and so my speech will not be printed out
I'm not going to destroy trees and the
forest so you want to read it go to the
internet to go to my website so what
about I will I mention a bit about
Afghanistan I mention about Middle East
and I say in based on our experience we
can label people today terrorists
shenanigans mom was labeled a criminal a
terrorist was even put in jail Nelson
Mandela wasted 26 27 years yes there are
a fact a terrorist quote unquote but
sooner or later the same people you call
terrorists in the past you invite them
back for dialogue and then they become a
statesman I'm not trying to simplify but
I was put in the referring to the Middle
East issue Hamas Hezbollah well these
are genuine popular uprisings these are
genuine popular movements they want
elections in Gaza the whole
international community support the
elections we want election in Gaza well
oops
ha ha mas want sorry
Hamas that's not what we had in mind so
of course the leadership of Hamas if you
want to lead a community if you want to
lead a nation you have you have ought to
be responsive and responsible
you and what Hamas is doing is leading
the Palestinians to self-destruction so
as much as I agree I don't agree with
the policies of the US and Europe in
ostracize Hamas in denying them the
possibility to govern in Gaza I also
find it irresponsible on the part of
Hamas leadership in what they are doing
so the two sides have to do something
now in Afghanistan is the same you know
only a few weeks ago a few months ago
Security Council passed a resolution
labeling terrorists most of Afghan up up
Taliban leaders well few months ago they
did another resolution or a decision
take off that because we need to
negotiate with them so we label people
better for terrorists and for whatever
reasons of course some day they are
irresponsible obviously the Taliban what
they do to their own people in the past
and today well do not inspire trust in
that they can govern their people with
responsibility but you have to talk with
them and and in my experience personal
experience all these many years personal
experience on the ground in timor-leste
in day to day challenge the day to day
conflicts in 206 I spent countless hours
talking with the youth talking with the
martial art gangs and sometimes out of
curiosity to understand what the hell
are they fighting for so you sit down
with and listen to them and then you
understand
and sometimes just because you listen to
them they come down they're human beings
someone's listening to them then you
move on the next steps I launched a
program in timor-leste called
the city of peace and as part of the
daily city of peace campaign with the
generosity of the Minister of Finance
who allocated some money to the
President to do my social programs what
I did I launched small housing projects
two thousand dollars a little house very
humble I went to the communities I asked
them the poor people the gangs to define
with me what is extreme poverty and we
agree on the definition someone who
doesn't have a roof and will sleep on
the dirt floor so I said I have limited
money I can do only two houses per
barrel pair suco so you choose the
people who you feel must have it is
first two houses and the shows and they
found the land and I gave them some cash
building material and we have had these
houses and not a single dispute over the
land over the house but by engaging them
feeling that so the gangs the you
suddenly they are doing good for their
own community and the government is very
happy with a program starting next year
well already started last two years but
next year a massive program I think five
thousand Emilio many houses eleven
thousand houses of this kind of houses
three four thousand dollars each next
year but built by the communities the
cash goes to them so these are things
that my experience that we do of course
Afghan Afghanistan is far far more
complex is like day and night but my
advice as I said you know
article in Wall Street Journal in
November last year that I pounded they
asked me to write I wrote an article on
Afghanistan what it will take to bring
about peace in Afghanistan I would say
wait till the elections the lecture will
be held at the time
Karzai warned and negotiation Taliban
must begin the only way out to the
Afghan problem and that's again is not
guaranteed solution but there is no
other way you know so that's my long
answer to your simple question sorry mr.
president thank you for a absolutely
remarkable talk and for sharing the
ideas your country's very lucky to have
you and we're very lucky to have you and
I would just want you to know how
inspired so many of us here are at
Columbia University by what you're
accomplishing and how proud we are to be
working together with your government
and we know that the accomplishments
will go on and on and I have a public
bet that you will grow faster than China
this decade so I'm counting on you to to
follow through on that I got something
on the line too please join me in
thanking the president
you